[Musique]
stéphane chétrit enfin qui aura la plus
longue spéciale canicule on va prendre
tous les deux un [ __ ] ici balle tirée
il ya bien sûr c'est comme la courte
paille temps lui qui a la plus courte et
bien on a vu qu'à la plus longue
d'ailleurs pourra donc plus longue
voilà donc la voie là où là on commence
avec ça choisissez prenez la rouge pas
mal je suis pas mal bon il est pas mal
non franchement je ne sais pas du tout
haha tu vois
ah pardon paix
merde ah ouais c'est la même chose que
la belle ait ôté même coiffure et non
j'adore mes amis autant d'autos garde
qu'il l'a battu en play merci on a on a
le deuxième point le deuxième on doit
sortir voilà la regarde et on va aller
dans plusieurs endroits là là là
regardez là on a ça c'est comme ça
qu'est comme ça d'accord aulas ça il
faut qu'ils réussissent eu alors vous
voulez que choisit son premier jeu vous
jouerais je sais rien du tout d'accord
achats sont pas du tout la musique est
formidable bien ça y est c'est une cata
bien si elle aura troisième énorme après
il ya ainsi siao merde non ça passe ça
passe stoica au maire
[Applaudissements]
bah c'est bon sens le métro par ses
plats attention le qui aura la plus
longue
stéphane alesi choisissez le perdant
devra se mettre là et le gagnant aura
une petite tige et bien sûr voilà voilà
mais c'est très sympa vous inquiétez pas
réglé la qui je l'aï cela parce que
c'est moi qui ai gagné alors allez-y
stéphane c'est un jeu digne de la taupe
alors j'aimerais aller je galère avec
ses dirigeants
et bien sûr
alors
[Musique]
la gueule égard alors stéphane allé
battre cocla on y va ça en pet et oui
j'ai un deal à vous faire si vous si
vous prenez ma place demain je dirais
toutes les missions toutes les cinq
minutes qui a qui est la taupe sur m6 a
je crois je prends bon bah voilà allez
c'est bon bah voilà
allez merci voilà cinq minutes et sa
ministre le 10 pensent que pendant des
heures que j'attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]